bloodthirsty cyborg bears a bad case of
crabs and the girl who performed at my
bachelorette party love death and robots
is back for season 3 with a new swarm of
animated shorts that make me thankful i
live in our current [ __ ] of a
world in this video we'll be taking a
deep dive into each short and as always
i'll leave timestamps below so you can
fast forward to your favorite ones three
robots is our first sequel in the love
death and robots universe if you
remember back in season one these guys
were on a quest to learn about
humanity's downfall because if they can
learn how humanity failed maybe they
won't make the same mistakes and i gotta
say this short is the most blatantly
political of the bunch poking fun at
right-wing doomsday preppers liberal
elites and wealthy tech billionaires in
season 1 we learned that humanity fell
apart due to its inability to combat
climate change and here we pick things
up to see how various strata of society
dealt with this change it's ironic that
the downfall of each of these groups
becomes the very thing they once
supported for example the poor doomsday
gun toting preppers who believed in
limited government no government
healthcare and a hell of a lot of guns
well they'll end up living in a lawless
world with no government no healthcare
and where they live in fear of being
killed by rival gun-toting preppers we
have the rich tech millionaires who
converted oil rigs into their very own
sovereign nations and the irony isn't
lost on me that they're now living on
the very thing that brought upon the
world's downfall in the first place the
burning of fossil fuels their reliance
on technology would be their own demise
as the ai they installed worked against
him and they brought no one on board
that had practical skills needed to
survive finally there are these secret
undercover bunkers save for members of
the government as america the beautiful
plays in the background we learned their
hydroponic cultivation system failed one
run by a man named steven t millerdorff
which might actually be a reference to
tim miller the showrunner i mean it
kinda looks like him democracy which got
these men here in the first place will
be their death when they invoke
quote-unquote extreme democracy on who
to cannibalize next in the liftoff
footage in which billionaires paid to be
evacuated off planet we can see this
apocalypse takes place around the year
2025 but one of the robots makes the
point that if these billionaires
actually pooled all their money into
solving the climate crisis and making
the future better for their children
they'd never have to build these ships
and escape in the first place it's a
pretty bleak message and warning for the
times we have the tools to stop our
dependence on fossil fuels right now yet
we don't but the short actually ends on
a lighthearted note with super
intelligent cats have taken over the
mars colony season one's three robots
episode ended with these cats who were
genetically engineered to have opposable
thumbs and can somehow talk and i for
one welcome our cat overlords
traveling probably where the entire
season's budget went just to pay david
fincher who directed this episode this
is maybe my first or second favorite of
the season you can try to guess what my
second one is and that's because of what
it says about humanity greed and making
the right choice the plot revolves
around thorin who sees himself on a
jabil shark expedition the jabil shark
is a coveted animal due its secretion of
valuable oil with a ship under attack
and basically held hostage by this crab
like thanopod thorin strikes a deal with
it it wants to be let off on nearby
fadin island in order for it and its
babies to feed off this populous town so
thorne and the crew have a choice they
can either save themselves and drop the
monster off on this unsuspecting town
killing the innocent townsfolk or they
can trick the thanopod by releasing it
on a neighboring deserted island but
thorin is cunning and finds out everyone
on the ship has put themselves before
the town if he lets the crew succeed
many more will die and the crew is
pretty greedy and a corrupt lot to begin
with even though thorin didn't draw the
short straw they still make him deal
with the phanopod they also try to kill
him multiple times once when he's up on
the mast and the second time while he's
sleeping thorin's cunning proves to be
his most valuable asset as he one by one
tricks the crew into becoming thanopod
food and eventually tricks the thanopod
itself using barrels of jabel shark oil
to set fire to the ship and destroy the
creature or at least the episode implies
that it has died the final image is of
thorin rowing towards the innocence of
faden island away from the greed and
corruption of the fiery wreckage love
death and robot's third installment this
season is based off the 1999 hugo award
for best short story the very pulse of
the machine in fact near the beginning
of this short you'll see a book called
poems of old earth and the author is the
same one who wrote the book this episode
is based on after her rover crashes on
the surface of jupiter's moon io
astronaut martha kivelson must travel
back to her lander before her air supply
runs out it's a 41 kilometer journey and
she decides to bring her dead partner
along with her talk about a literal dead
weight it's an arduous trek with martha
having to administer drugs which cause
her to hallucinate and hear the very
voice of the planet itself the voice
recites lines of poetry one of them
being from william wordsworth's she was
a phantom of delight which has the line
and now i see with i serene the very
pulse of the machine it's fitting then
the final image of this short is the eye
of jupiter overlooking the machine that
is io a machine which has made martha a
part of it when martha learns she won't
make it to the lander in time io tells
her to jump into the sulfur her body may
disappear but it's possible her neural
configuration may be preserved the last
line is of martha calling out to earth
suggesting that she successfully joined
with io and became one with the planet
of course the ending here is ambiguous
it's entirely possible this was all a
hallucination and martha died hopped up
on tons of drugs i mean that's probably
how i'd want to go too night of the mini
dead was so damn fun i didn't want it to
end it takes the overdone zombie genre
but presents it in a way that's visually
stimulating and fun as all hell yeah one
of the gas stations is called hell even
the way the zombie apocalypse starts is
pretty unique with a horny couple
desecrating a cemetery and an upside
down cross acting as a lightning conduit
to awaken the dead what starts as a
small spattering of zombies quickly
escalates all around the globe including
my home country of canada where we have
a sudden death at the maple center which
is a non to the maple leafs however if
this were actually in canada center
would be spelled the british way
c-e-n-t-r-e
i'm a nitpicking piece of [ __ ] we have
shaolin monks fighting off zombies the
pope and priests using machine guns i
didn't realize until this later but we
have freedom loving build the wall types
ironically trying to get over the border
wall these little political jobs are
pretty hilarious little details like the
fedex truck labeled [ __ ] and the go
green save the planet garbage truck are
nice touches completely overrun the u.s
launches nukes which russia then
retaliates and the entire planet blows
up but it's the ending that continually
pushes out from the earth that really
accentuates how tiny or should i say
mini we are in the grand scheme of
things the medium in which this story is
told mini stop motion becomes a metaphor
for how humanity is but a tiny blip in
the universe nestled smack dab in the
middle of season 3 is kill team kill and
over the top gorefest that shows us what
happens when we take playing god too far
in fact the first image of the short is
a soldier taking a piss over the
mountainside below proclaiming that he's
an angel with the reach of god the team
is attacked by a genetically engineered
grizzly bear which we find out was a
secret cia project known as project
bargust bargast is a creature from
english folklore who was a monstrous
goblin dog with huge teeth and claws
that only appeared at night maybe that's
why their first battle is at night a
nice homage to that what this episode
really showcases is how humanity's
hubris can lead to its own demise the
perfect example of this is when one of
the soldiers claims victory and is
immediately mauled to death even the
ending which sees the bear's eye
self-destruct and kill everyone points
at the futility of playing god as it
will eventually come to bite us in the
ass this swarm examines the lengths to
which man will go to continue the human
race we start with dr aphriel afriola
hebrew name meaning angel of youth or
one that encourages newness and
exploration which is exactly what the
doctor is attempting to explore this
ancient alien race with the hopes of
using it to strengthen humanity this
alien species is known as the swarm and
are considered as close to perfectly
organized as species can get so it makes
sense humans would want to study them dr
aphriel teams up with dr galena whose
name means calm or healer from its
slavic russian origin she acts as our
and dr aphriel's introduction to this
strange world whereas galena admires the
gracefulness and perfection of this
organic system which he also refers to
as genetic automation afril wants to
harness it to bring order to humanity's
expansion imagine if humanity were able
to create their own swarm fully decked
out with millions of swarmed slaves who
they could program to work for them it
would be an absolute game changer so
afrion galena begin a series of tests to
see just how greatly they can influence
the various types of species tests which
incorporate the use of pheromones
similar to how ants operate in a colony
but these tests are short-lived when the
swarm finds out about their plans you
don't get to be a successful
million-year-old race without
recognizing an enemy is fooling around
under your watch earlier in the short we
learned that galena recognized 15
subspecies of the swarm which could
communicate using language which she
thinks is the result of the swarm having
absorbed previous space-faring races and
this absorption is what we see happen to
her at the end the swarm has made her
one of them creating a new species whose
purpose in the greater colony is that of
intelligence she makes reference to this
scavenger creature feeding on afriel's
vomit millions of years ago this
creature's ancestors were an intelligent
race that fought with the swarm but the
swarm bred smarter tougher versions of
them until they became victorious now
their offspring millennia later are
stuck as scavengers to clean up vomit
afril is given a choice remain an
intelligent living being likely under
the control of the swarm or perish in
what the swarm calls real ugly events
just like afrial came to study the swarm
in the hopes of improving humanity i
think the tables have now turned the
swarm want aphro alive to study him so
that when humanity does pose a threat to
them in the future they'll outmatch them
every time afril accepting the swarm's
offer one in which he calls a challenge
is but an example of humanity's
arrogance in fact earlier in the short
galena even refers to afril as being
arrogant and it's this arrogance which
the swarm will use to its advantage to
manipulate him into working with them he
says humans will never become parasites
but in accepting this offer he
unknowingly dooms humanity to that very
fate mason's rats envisions a not too
distant future in which rats wear really
cool belts actually they've adapted to
keep up with us pesky humans the main
plot revolves around mason who hires a
pest control company to deal with the
rats taking over his barn and what
starts as a light-hearted tale about
getting rid of rats turns into a
metaphor for war itself on one side you
have mason fully equipped with the
latest tech to take on the less equipped
rats who use arrows in fact mason's tech
acts much like drones they handle the
dirty work while you sit back and watch
from computer screens much of the
fighting in this short wii nor mason
actually see it happens within the walls
of the barn just like drone strikes in
iraq were conducted remotely halfway
around the world by american soldiers in
nevada it isn't until mason sees
firsthand the absolute brutality of his
actions full with little rat families
being obliterated that he empathizes
with them they aren't so different after
all even one of the rats wears a
scottish tam just like him even though
we fight each other on earth we seem to
forget that deep down we're all the same
we're all human the two sides sit down
and in a show of friendship have a drink
together in vaulted halls entombed the
theme of war continues when a group of
american soldiers attempt to rescue a
hostage held captive by some insurgents
this leads them to a dangerous network
of caves revealing an ancient enslaved
creature it's bound by chains and the
pillars surrounding it are covered in
glowing runes which when the creature
touches seem to sizzle it's as if some
great power or magic is holding it at
bay now i won't go over those cannibal
roach things they're merely the tomb's
protectors i want to focus on what
happens once they reach this prison the
two characters who make it this far are
serge and harper and when we're
introduced to this thing it lets out a
piercing screech which conjures these
destructive images of what the world
will become harper sees piles of flaming
corpses in the creature amongst burning
buildings if this thing is released as
he asks to be this is likely what will
happen it seems this creature has the
ability to mind control as we'll see
sarge attempt to unchain it but when
harper tries to stop him he attacks and
is killed it's clear he's not himself
and it's here where things get a bit
ambiguous
harper discharges her remaining bullets
at the creature but it looks as though
she's about to be lulled into a mind
control too our next shot is of her in
the desert with her eyes cut out
carrying what is likely the same knife
sarge used to attack her with if you
have the subtitles on it says she's
whispering a quote alien language
basically confirming that she has or was
taken over now i don't know about you
but if i was haunted by images of the
world being destroyed i might just scoop
out my eyes too that's what i think this
symbolizes her wanting to rid herself of
the images of a destroyed world that or
the creature is just really messed up
and wanted to have some fun finally we
have jabarro and this short has been on
my mind the most of any in the entire
series we start in autumn a time of year
symbolizing a transition to death or
winter which mimics what our characters
go through we know this is a fantastical
world by these strange almost neon-like
flowers yet it has an almost don quixote
spanish conquistador type vibe the word
jabarro is derived from puerto rico to
refer to the countryside people who
farmed the land in a traditional way and
the tale itself is a re-imagination of
siren folklore from greek mythology
sirens were dangerous creatures who use
their voice to lure their victims to
their own demise before the siren's
appearance we see the men showing their
allegiance to a group of priests
although the men appear to be here on a
holy mission it's clear their true
intentions lay with greed and gold this
is symbolized in the siren who is
adorned with gold jewelry and various
ornaments the siren in jabar lures the
men into a frenzy who fight each other
into the lake to get closer to her it's
a fool's errand as their armor sinks
them into the depths there is however
one survivor jabarro a death knight
impervious to the siren shrieks when you
watch this short from the lens of
colonialism the plot makes a lot more
sense the resource-rich siren or the
colonized in this scenario is sought
after by the conquistador or colonizer
at first the colonized is curious about
this new group the two even engage in a
macabre love affair only for the
colonizer to take full control and rape
both figuratively and literally the
knight takes everything from her ridding
the body of its riches and dumping it
when it ceases to be useful the siren's
body floats back from whence it came
unleashing a torrent of blood symbolic
of the bloodshed its people endured it's
only when the knight unknowingly drinks
of this blood the blood that he has shed
does he regain his hearing making him
susceptible to the siren's whale the
siren emerges from the lake now naked
and broken you can see the agony in her
face she lures the knight in and he like
those before him lay on the bottom among
a sea of dead bodies there are no
winners in this story the soldiers die
and the woman is left alone and broken
it's a tragedy caused by greed jabarro
is haunting and one of my favorites in
the entire love and death robots
universe but what did you think of this
season and which short made the top of
your list i want to know in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on twitter
and instagram at thinkstoryyt until next
time remember this is where i come to
jurgo
you